I'm in this weird window at hbl where
they read these scripts and they say
okay do this and and I'm I say yes and I
go back and I do them but there's a
little part of me thinking are they you
know were they really thinking about
what they just did and you know I think
they are in some respects you know I'm
part of a brand that it's a wide brand
and I'm some weird little politicized
PBS part of it how hard is it to make
something like this now having done the
wire haven't done for me having done
generation kill here a miniseries about
they're all hard they're hard in their
way I think the team I work with I think
we're getting better at it I think our
level of execution on the last few
projects is stronger each time out
trying to washes away stuff you learn
what works you learn what doesn't this
one was this was a little bit
astonishing because you know it's a
six-part miniseries about race and
politics and an urban planning and you
know think about the sentence I just
said that's not exactly you know
appointment television you started
working on this 15 years ago how much of
recent events sort of influenced how the
final script came together when we
finish the last significant draft of the
scripts it was before Ferguson before
Baltimore before Charleston it was not
before any number of other stories that
highlight our unique American pathology
when it comes to race and class I mean
this stuff's on going if we'd have made
it two years ago it wouldn't have been
Ferguson it wouldn't have been but but
somewhere there would have been a
dynamic that would have raised the same
questions because this is the perennial
fight we've grown into our adolescence
when it comes to racial issues I think
as a country most of us now no you can't
sling around the racial epithets that's
not you know those things won't play so
we have a vernacular that allows us to
play the same games but now it's all
about personal freedom and liberty and
and my property values and
not in my backyard ISM and you know but
what it really comes down to is fear I
know that in light of the riots and
Baltimore people were looking to you to
respond to them you find yourself now in
a position where people want to hear
what you have to say we're not or not I
suppose yeah do you embrace that what's
it like to have that I don't know I
don't think I even think in terms of
embracing and I live in Baltimore that's
where I live and that night I was
worried for people who were very close
friends of mine who lived very close to
the areas that were on fire my city
still recovering from 1968 we just
stopped losing population a few years
ago and to hear a lot of people in the
wake of what happened in Baltimore
talking about the validity of the night
of the protests but of the riot that was
very disturbing to me because you know
come to Baltimore and say that that's
it's a very cynical thing to say when in
fact we live there and the fragility of
the city is such as it is you know our
recoveries is not assured in any sense
you sat down with the president talked
about some of these issues with him
curious just how easy it is to be on the
platform that you're on having an
audience like that being able to address
some of these it wasn't easy that day I
mean you know you look up we're about
this far apart you look up and you're in
the middle of a sentence and there's the
president the freaking United States
it's like what you know there's a little
moment of where was I I'm a huge fan of
the wire I think it's one of the
greatest not just television shows but
pieces of art in the last couple of
decades the opportunity to do it lent
itself to advancing probably the most
seminal thing that I covered as a
reporter and that I've written about in
television which is ending the drug war
and and ending this level of
incarceration curious degree to which
you think about the future of television
in your place in it are you somebody
watches it at all avidly or it takes
interest and where things might be held
I have to I have to invoke the image of
the wandering June always have one bag
packed because you never know when it's
going to go south on you
that's from my heritage sort of a post
per gram sensibility but at some point I
expect somebody to come to me and say
you know we've looked at your ratings
and you know you've let you go a long
time but you know it's you haven't had a
hit Kid and and you still feel that way
yeah I do i do I mean I've been at HP of
17 years and I'm going to work on some
pilots and maybe one of them will get
picked up but I'm never quite believing